la raison du mal à la tête
[Musique]
Jonathan Cohen m'a mis une table dans le
dos tu crois que je vais me laver
écoute franchement
vu que j'avais les mains propres ça ne
laissera aucune trace ni sur tes
fringues ni sur ton corps donc a priori
lève-toi lève-toi s'il te plaît
c'est quoi
[Musique]
pauvre tu demandes à Jean-Paul Gaultier
son meilleur conseil mode
surtout aucun conseil parce qu'il ne
faut pas des conseils il faut faire
soi-même ce qu'on ressent ce en quoi on
se sent bien et ce qu'on veut dire à
travers la mode ou ce qu'on veut porter
tout simplement donc pas de conseil
faites ce qui vous plaît c'est ça et j'y
vais surtout pas les autres ils ont
Island j'adore le Nail homme
qu'est-ce que tu fais
pourquoi